foreign
ER I've been deconstructing and
inspecting designer luxury leather bags
to help people understand if it's worth
it or not and I'm gonna walk you through
how I deconstruct the 1100 Gucci
Dionysus mini bag
the most misused term in the industry
it's genuine leather you know it may
mean really low qualities of leather and
some people use it in a very misleading
ways I try to put my estimates on the
leather and craftsmanship cost so people
can make that deduction like how much of
this price is now status coming from the
brand and make your mind by yourself
right
I look at three things first is leather
like what type of leather selection was
employed in this design how
good of a leather is required for this
kind of finish they employed here two is
the craftsmanship the sophistication of
the design and finally the third one is
overall performance value compared to
that price point if you're looking for
just leather you don't care about status
it might be too much for you and if you
are okay you want to buy the status that
comes with the brand then it's totally
worth it for you so that's that's my
intention of helping people with this
information this Buckle is attached to
it very strongly through these metal
connections and it is really hard for me
to take it off so I am cutting the
Buckle off from the leather to take it
out of my way so we can start inspecting
the weather
Gucci bag has about two three layers of
supporting materials inside so leather
is back in by this fabric which will
prevent the stretching of the leather
over time so it's going to make sure the
the form stays intact in in you know
years to come there's some thicker
supports almost resembling cardboard
kind of materials sometimes leather dust
is employed in those support materials
as well to increase the structure
rigidity of the bag this Dionysus bag
was very rigid and structured bag it
looked felt and stayed very solid in its
given form and it was very well executed
like super good craftsmanship very good
design and all that internal pieces was
carefully planned selected and the
stitching lines the even the counts of
the stitches quality seems really good I
think the
the shop making this bag definitely a
top-notch Artisan shop
now I'm applying some acetone because
it's a very common household dissolver
and I'm using a sharp knife or a little
leather blade to remove the Finish it's
technically like scraping off a little
bit of a cream from top of the leather
and there is no certain depth I go until
I see the leather grain by leather grain
I'm talking about the pores of the the
hair cells actually you will start
seeing the hair cells beyond the Finish
once those plasticky gooey substance is
gone and that gooey substance it's just
liquidized plastic
[Music]
the finish on it the the that pattern
embossed finish is a thick heavy finish
underneath when I open the bags I know
this is good leather after touching it
seeing the back side of it and all that
this is subjective the Leathers I love
has this minimal finish where I see the
natural grain of leather because leather
is a non-standard natural material just
like you know everybody's skin looks
slightly different truly minimally
finished Artisan Leathers make unique
pieces no two leather craft will look
alike that's what I appreciate in
another but I know this is really almost
impossible for big Brands to go with due
to their size they need some form of
standardization
foreign
strips so I can burn it and understand
from the burning characteristics what
kind of tanning was involved in this
leather
leather can be 10 different ways they
all burn slightly differently and they
leave different residues ashes Chrome 10
leather Burns really slow you have to
force it to keep burning and then the
ash is Will usually show some form of
green residue which is the color of the
Chrome tanning agent 90 in my estimate
of leathers all right Chrome 10 because
it's convenient easy quick and very
durable and everybody uses it but it's a
heavy metal and it's more polluting in
the in the tanning technique
metal three leather is in fairly new
tanning technique I would say all it's
becoming more popular in the couple
decades
Gucci bag has a metal free claim and
grain sometimes they call it grain or
pebble calf skin leather and this is the
little Pebbles they refer to when
they're talking about that which is a
standardization finish so the leather
they used here is showing me no signs of
chrome which is confirming their claim
of metal-free thinning and that's as
much as I can tell from this this test
it doesn't tell too much of the details
when you're talking about Metal free
tank but at least we don't see signs of
Chrome
in my opinion this bag can be made about
115 dollars in leather and labor
material cost it was definitely well
made it's beautiful leather employed
here the quality of craftsmanship and
accessories is exceptional of course
it's a big brand it's Gucci there is a
premium definitely you're paying in the
price of eleven hundred dollars because
eventually regardless how good of a
leather you use price doesn't go above a
certain point because of the leather
then when you start seeing astronomical
prices you know that it's not about the
leather anymore it's about the status
comes with the price that's the whole
point of my question of is it worth it
or not leather is not cheap but it's
never astronomically expensive
foreign
[Music]